hi I'm Lottie and the beauty editor here
at Glamour UK hi I'm Kara I'm a beauty
blogger and makeup artist
I'm Sam Glamour's deputy beauty editor
and you're watching glamour tries today
I'm going to be using the laura mercier
translucent powder and the new glow
translucent powder usually I don't want
a translucent powder because I find it
makes me cakey I've heard very good
things as someone with oily and
sensitive skin it's the perfect product
to keep my makeup in place throughout
the day today I'm on a really long shoot
so I'm definitely going to be putting on
my translucent powder because it helps
my makeup last all day it picks up a lot
of product that is one good path press
and roll press and roll oh my god that's
already like soaked up any ounce of
shine another great thing about this
product is it really reduces fine lines
and minimize the pores got Kashmir talc
in it which is what makes it so so
smooth and silky it's making me feel
like fresh baby out of the womb so I'm
gonna go with the globe powder now I'm
gonna dab DUP DUP it's really really
light reflecting because of the pearl
pigments inside so you see the product
in there obviously has a color so I
really just did not know what this was
gonna look like I'm just gonna add a
little warm so this is my face without
it with I mean wow that's so nice
that's
right there that's good so checking this
afternoon and we'll see how both of the
powders go
so I'm just waiting to go into a brunch
meeting and wanted to check in and see
if my makeup was still okay but it's
perfectly sack my skin still looks
really really glowy and lovely I just
wanted to do a quick check in and see if
I had any shine but I'm super happy with
it so far I've actually received so many
compliments on my skin today so I know
that it's not cakey whatsoever either
I'm on set I just thought I'd check in
I've been on two hot lights for a few
hours now and I'm still looking really
really mad and it feels great on my skin
so so far so good
it is completely matched I have never
been so happy with the translucent
powder before still have that radiant
finish on the cheekbones where I applied
the glow powder and I haven't had to
reapply all day which is great for my
sensitive skin the less product the
better for me so flawless were you happy
with this thanks so much for watching
guys if you have tried the original
Laura Mercier powder before let me know
in the comments below we'd love to know
what you think if you get the chance to
try the new glow one as well which is
just launched let us know in the
comments below I'd love to hear what you
think of it don't forget to subscribe to
glamour UK's YouTube channel and follow
glamour UK
[Music]